December 18th 2015 the quarantine zone
in the middle of Manhattan later known
as the dark zone was abandoned by the
government and the Joint Task Force they
left behind weapons equipment thousands
of civilians and the first wave of
division agents although it has assumed
that the majority of the first wave were
killed or went rogue there are a number
that just simply disappeared what we do
know is that some of them managed to
escape the quarantine zone and make
their way to the outside of Manhattan
Island in this series we're going to
follow these agents and speculate on
what happened to them based on the
psychological profiles and the location
of where their watches and other
information was fountain
[Music]
Michael Trudeau's watchin ID can be
found underground in the south of the
Chelsea district as a child Michael was
a chess prodigy he attended Tulane
University on a scholarship where he
graduated with a double major in physics
and game theory from here he moved into
the financial sector but five years
later he quit he followed his natural
talent and became a professional poker
player in his career he won eight public
tournaments but he made his real living
in high stakes private games
Michael thrives on high risk in
competition but this isn't to say that
he's reckless
quite the opposite really he's a
calculated individual only taking risks
after careful consideration of the odds
involved when the percentages appear in
his favor
you're ruthless he sees the
opportunities as they present themselves
Michael is a master strategist and an
expert in reading other people's motives
and intentions as a former college
decathlete his physical abilities along
ciders of high intelligence make him a
valuable asset for the strategic
homeland division Michael's watch an ID
can be found underground in the south of
the Chelsea district the area is under
the control of a number of different
writer games taking the opportunity to
gain control the water damage to his ID
shows that he's been down there for a
while given that he's such a calculated
individual he was likely taking refuge
waiting and listening into the comms
before making his next move he was very
close to Camp Hudson where he was likely
making his way back to be given that has
now become public knowledge that a large
number of the first wave have turned
their backs on the government and gone
rogue
perhaps he was waiting to see if any
other first wave agents turned up before
making his next move as it was unknown
how he would be treated upon entering
the camp unknown to whom his hideout was
also an area that had been targeted by
the cleaners in an attempt to cut off
the water supply potentially he was
overwhelmed by the hostile affection
while defending his position and the
water pumps or maybe the cleaners forced
his hand he said any indication of being
a division agent and escaped moving
towards Camp Hudson disguised as a
civilian in need where he's been holding
up ever since
you
you
Ellen
Jenkins watch an ID can be found in
Hell's Kitchen next to the Clinton
district Eleanor was a typical military
brat as her father was a servicemen who
moved the family frequently stationed in
Germany her mother was a German national
born in a military base eleanor picked
up the local languages everywhere they
went by the time she graduated high
school she was fluent in heat languages
eleanor studied at Barnard College a
private woman's liberal art college in
Manhattan right out of college she
joined an international consulting firm
from there she moved into the UN to
serve as a translator Eleanor's been
married once there's now been divorced
for six years as a deeply introverted
individual she doesn't trust easily and
is completely unseen to me until about
coworkers
Eleanor avoids conflict wherever
possible careful and methodical she
prefers to observe and then
problem-solve but she isn't to be taken
as a pushover preferring hobbies like
rock climbing and martial arts
she is more than capable of defending
herself if required after things started
falling apart in the dark zone Eleanor
ran west together their appearance as a
deeply introverted individual she was
comfortable dropping off the group and
keeping to herself as at this time it
was difficult to know just who to trust
Eleanor took to the rooftops we should
have a good vantage point of the
goings-on around her on the streets
below dropping her communications and
tracking equipment they could have her
found she's likely long gone from the
area but could still be hiding out in
Hell's Kitchen and Clinton districts of
the city Eleanor is likely still hiding
out in the western side of Manhattan
observing and taking notes on what has
been happening over this event in New
York City
if the shd ever find agent Eleanor
Jenkins she is likely to have vast
amounts of valuable intel on the hostile
faction movements and Western Manhattan
you
Jerr
chuckles watch an ID can be found in
Hudson yard Jeremy has that experience
as a public defender for the last six
years
his represented criminal defendants from
many different backgrounds and cultures
through this line of work he has a deep
understanding of criminal psychology as
well as a broad knowledge of criminal
activity organization and techniques
Jeremy has a stubborn streak he took
fewer plea deals than any other lawyer
in the public defender's office he
prefers confrontational to compromise
his belief in clients is often used to
justify his approach this is an asset as
well as a potential risk jeremy thrives
on pressure the more difficult the
situation the more committed he is to
solving it however here's the occasional
tendency to push the limit beyond what
is necessary when Alice confrontational
solution could be found
Jeremy Carmichael's watch an ID was
found in a secluded area of the Hudson
Yards this was a considerable distance
from the dark zone where they were
originally left the dead and the trail
to find this information was moving
further away from the dark zone and more
towards the Westside peers there were no
signs of struggle and the hostile
factions were few and far between
perhaps he was fleeing the situation and
when he learned that the other agents
going rogue and that they were hunting
down others that refused to join he
stripped himself of his watch so he
couldn't be tracked down however this
doesn't really work in with his profile
as a stubborn individual that thrives on
pressure and confrontation perhaps he
was moving towards Cape Hudson to
regroup with other agents though this
doesn't necessarily explain why he
removed his watch when it was so close
however the more troubling likelihood is
that he joined up with Erin keener and
was working towards future plans in the
wizard peers he may have decided to
shoot his watch when it was apparent
that the division had learned of the
actions of the first wave division
agents to reduce the chance of being
tracked down particularly as he was
working towards an objective that kina
didn't want the division to know about
until much later on
LaMarcus Henry's watchin ID can be found
on the edge of a Hudson yard district
the Marcus Henry was a former police
officer who worked in South Central Los
Angeles as part of a street gang task
force the street experience would bring
real world relevance to his academic
studies LaMarcus holds a BA in
anthropology from UCLA and a doctorate
in sociology from Berkeley University
where as thesis examined the social
organization of urban street gangs as a
noted expert in criminal behavior he
brings an invaluable level of expertise
to the division experience as a police
officer could some exceptional
situational awareness the Marcus knows
how to defuse violent situations or meet
with force of the situation demands it
however empathy for an understanding of
the criminal subculture could cut both
ways the Marcus Henry's watch an ID was
found in the Hudson yard district right
on the edge of the island it's likely
that he fled the dark zone
not long after the JTF withdrew it's
possible that on his way to the edge of
the island he ran into a number of
Reiter gangs using his expertise he may
have chosen to defuse the situation and
work towards bringing peace back to the
Seri of the city his empathy and
understanding of the situation these
people are in may have taken him away
from his original goals of falling back
and regrouping with the JTF and other
division agents but why droppers watch
an ID it is possible that one of the
gangs turned on him the car parking
building where it was found was under
heavy control by the writers but
alternatively the Marcus was also
directly in the path of Jeremy
Carmichael on his way up to the Westside
piers LaMarcus and Jeremy may have run
into each other the meeting could have
gone a couple of ways
Jeremy was either able to convince
LaMarcus to join penis cause although
Marcus was simply convinced to come
along without knowing the full extent of
Jeremy's mission and his allegiance to
Aaron keener and his rogues either way
LaMarcus removed his watch and left the
area whether or not he agreed to join
kina was killed after turning it down
it's unlikely that we'll see or hear any
more of agent for the Marcus Henry
[Music]
as stated earlier what happened to these
agents is purely speculation reading
into events that occurred close by story
missions Intel psychological profiles
these can all give a fairly good
indication but what do you think
happened next week will follow another
group of loss to first wave agents and
see if we can help close some of the
gaps in the Intel that we've received so
far time to do another giveaway Ubisoft
Australia has given me a bunch of
division 1 games to hand out these are
for Xbox one and PlayStation 4 also
included is the limited edition middle
case if you're watching this video
you'll likely already own the game but
maybe have a friend or family member
would like your copy if you're
interested in jumping into the draw
check out the link in the description
I'll draw a winner for each platform in
a couple of weeks I really must thank
the awesome people on the screen right
now in particular div erode and foxy you
guys are seriously helping with keeping
the channel ticking along thanks again
anyway that's all for me thanks a lot
for watching and I'll see you in the
next one
Cheers
[Music]
you